it is wonderful to see all of you yes
canada
uh this show is so much fun especially
wanda your character is just so
sarcastic
and just you know she just makes life
hard for everybody
that's the first thing you notice did
you
because we all have one of those people
in our families right
do you have someone like that in your
family uh
i had a couple of aunts who were just
like that couple aren't
you know dearly so i think i'm picking
up the
picking up the you know the gauntlet and
continuing with that uh
that that attitude yeah yeah and mike
your character is trying to do right
and he just keeps missing the mark just
just a little bit
uh how would you describe him you know
what
i would describe benny as a uh
if if benny had this much sense
he wouldn't be funny at all
you know i mean he billy benny don't
bend he don't mean nobody
but he he don't he don't know you know
benny doesn't know
uh he's oblivious to a lot of things
and sometimes in life when you run into
people who just
don't know stuff they just don't know it
instead of you get mad it becomes funny
yeah it kim when you
the first episode you you're planning a
birthday party for your daughter and it
goes
pretty well at the end of it but it
makes me think about as a parent
it's hard to make sure everything is
organized are you good at
organizing and balance balancing at all
sometimes
um sometimes you know um the the main
thing is
um i didn't approach this as like a mom
or
a wife and that sort of thing it was
really about this woman
um and who she is and what and what her
arc and her journey
is um from feeling overlooked from
dealing with
you know the the the baby mama and
and all that comes with it um so i think
in her
own way she is quite the um the the
the juggler you know when it comes to
juggling her emotions and
schedules and and things like that but i
love that they did not create
typical characters even with relatable
they are they're not typical in how they
interact and how they exist
and wanda you're the co-creator of the
show and uh
also mike you're the showrunner
alongside so aside from the humor what
do you want
to get out of this
regina they just titled their titles
like we it's all good
i love them i know you guys are really
involved into it uh what do you want
viewers to get from the series
i'm sorry what was what was the last
part what do you want viewers to get
from this series
oh what i want people to get from the
series first a lot of laughs a good
i mean good solid belly laughs i want
people to
to say hey this show sees us they they
you know
they are are showcasing uh how most
americans are
living and i want them to see that you
know hey
we all have our flaws uh you have
family members who screw up but this is
how you deal with it and you still love
each other and you're there for each
other you got each other's backs and uh
i want them to you know fall fall in
and what does it mean for you kim that
the fact that netflix has taken on a
show like this is celebrating a family
well it means a lot you know they
certainly have a such a
a i mean just a mind-blowing um
um you know history with uh their
content and the type of characters
uh that live in their space the types of
families that live in their space so
uh to have the upshaw's you know it
makes sense i couldn't really see the
upshaw's living
anywhere else space-wise um but it
certainly uh it means a lot into the the
amount of support
i've been in this thing a long time and
i've not seen
this level of support that netflix has
given us from ted
all the way down every department every
executive everybody has shown this show
so much support from day one it's really
been incredible
so it's uh it's very exciting and it's
encouraging
you know when it is and you get that
kind of respect
for what you're bringing to the table
you